bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad está con nosotros
camila bustamante ella es periodista
autora de las ciervas una exhaustiva
investigación en la cual expone los
abusos sufridos por mujeres ligadas a la
comunidad de religiosas denominadas
yerbas del plan de dios del sodalicio de
vida cristiana una comunidad
perteneciente a la iglesia católica que
mira muchísimas gracias por tu presencia
en la entrevista muchas gracias por la
invitación
camina bueno algo para preguntarte en
primer lugar no y contárselo a toda la
comunidad internacional que quizás no
conoce tanto sobre el tema es que es el
sodalicio de vida cristiana y en
particular que son las hierbas del plan
de dios
perfecto bueno súper bueno a partir con
esta introducción porque nos ayuda a
entender
desde donde estamos hablando el
sodalicio de vida cristiana es una
organización de religiosos de hombres
fundada en perú o luis fernando figari y
esta organización se expandió a
distintos países del mundo con fuerte
presencia en latinoamérica en países
como chile ecuador colombia argentina
también en diferentes zonas y las
hierbas del plan de dios es una
comunidad que también funda luis
fernando figari pero es una comunidad de
monjas que funda este señor y que
también se expanden a latinoamérica con
una presencia muy fuerte estas son
religiosas son monjas las que
tradicionalmente conocemos como como
monjas con hábito con velo esas son las
siervas del plan de dios y que
pertenecen a esta organización fundada
por fígar y que dicho sea de paso es una
persona que ya está acusada de abusos de
distinto tipo incluyendo abuso sexual al
interior de la comunidad de hombres
te voy a hacer más adelante de camina
parte en particular algunas preguntas al
respecto de esta figura tan polémica
verdad bueno ya pudimos entender no las
hierbas del plan de dios sería como la
rama femenina no de lo que sería el
sodalicio de vida cristiana
ahora algo muy interesante de tu
investigación es que visibiliza un
problema que usualmente no es mostrado
me refiero al abuso ejercido por mujeres
contra otras mujeres no porque seamos
sinceros la mayoría de los casos que
conocemos corresponden a abusos
cometidos por sacerdotes contra jóvenes
varones no adolescentes o menores de
edad pero vamos a hablar de prácticas de
abusos sexuales entre mujeres hablas de
prácticas correctivas de suma violencia
hablas incluso también de abusos
sexuales con qué tipos de violencias te
encontraste camila así es primero
santiago efectivamente el abuso cometido
entre mujeres es un tema que conocemos
muy poco y ya tenemos una cultura que
sigue avalando y que sigue normalizando
ciertas prácticas de violencia hacia la
mujer una de ellas tiene que ver con el
abuso que cometen hombres o sacerdotes o
personas con autoridad dentro de la
iglesia hacia las mujeres pero esa misma
cultura nos hace suprimir al abusador
cuando es una mujer por lo tanto ahí me
encontré con un problema que era
entender el abuso que ocurre entre las
mujeres y cómo se da
este tipo de abuso suele ser bastante
parecido al que conocemos en otras
situaciones de abuso en la iglesia parte
con un abuso que es de poder un abuso
que es de autoridad hay una manipulación
psicológica una manipulación espiritual
por parte de las mujeres las autoridades
son las que cometen estos abusos esta
manipulación y van sometiendo poco a
poco a aquellas mujeres que están como
en escalones más abajo dentro de la
pirámide de poder dentro de la
institución la manipulación se logra
porque son varios factores pero te diría
que uno de los más importantes tiene que
ver
estamos hablando de un mundo espiritual
de mujeres que se quieren entregar a
dios y los abusos en el ámbito
espiritual son mucho más fáciles que
ocurran estamos hablando de un abstracto
que es cumplir la voluntad de dios el
plan de dios y también esto está
asociado al sacrificio que hay que hacer
en la vida diaria para poder cumplirlos
por lo tanto las mujeres que están
sometidas a los abusos acceden a las
distintas peticiones que les van
pidiendo sus autoridades que van
claramente en aumento de violencia
partimos por una violencia que tiene que
ver con una manipulación pero podemos
llegar a violencia física violencia
psicológica con malos tratos y también a
violencia sexual
tenemos autoridades dentro de las
hierbas del plan de dios está en abusado
sexualmente de jóvenes dentro de la
institución camina bueno precisamente
recibe un poco adelantadas no hay todo
respecto de lo que te voy a preguntar
ahora porque el año 2000 2015 fue un
momento clave de verdad cuando salió a
la luz todas estas denuncias de abuso
sexual de maltrato por parte de quien
mencionaba sólo informando fígar y quien
es el fundador nos justamente de él
de vida cristiana y comenzaste a
recordar muchas cosas de tu paso por las
hierbas que fue un paso muy particular
no ya nos contará al respecto de esto
precisamente quiero preguntar cómo fue
ese particular paso y también que se
despertó a partir de esa investigación
en vos que despertó sobre tu propia
experiencia no en las hierbas
efectivamente el 2015 en perú
precisamente estalla un escándalo en la
iglesia católica peruana muy muy grande
que tiene que ver con las acusaciones de
abuso de distinto tipo contra el
fundador del sodalicio de vida cristiana
la comunidad de hombres dentro de esos
abusos estaba el maltrato psicológico la
violencia física e incluso se hablaba de
esclavitud de luís fernando que tenía a
religiosos sometidos literalmente a un
estado de esclavitud y que tenían que
cumplir con todas sus peticiones también
había abuso sexual esto ocurre el 2015
en perú yo en ese momento vivía en chile
yo pertenecía a esta institución pero
desde chile cuando nosotros acá en chile
nos empezamos a enterar de lo que estaba
pasando en perú y personas abusadas e
incluso sexualmente estamos hablando de
menores de edad
empezamos a indagar en la comunidad que
existía acá en chile sobre estos abusos
y nos dimos cuenta que más allá de los
abusos había toda una cultura sectaria
una cultura de autoritarismo que también
se vivía en otras comunidades como las
siervas del plan de dios mi aproximación
a las hierbas del plan de dios tiene que
ver con una etapa personal de mi vida en
donde yo estuve a punto de entrar a esta
organización religiosa
estuve discerniendo mi vocación con
ellas como se les suele decir a este
proceso en que una joven trata de
investigar o de averiguar si dios la
quiere o no la quiere para ese tipo de
vida religiosa
entonces cuando está en el escándalo del
sodalicio yo me doy cuenta que mucho de
lo que yo había vivido en términos de
autoritarismo de humillaciones de
maltrato era muy similar a lo que estaba
apareciendo en torno al sodalicio fue
ahí cuando empecé a reunir testimonios
de otras jóvenes que habían participado
y de más de 30 extra ligio sas de las
hierbas del plan de dios que me han
contado distintos casos de abuso y de
violencia
me hablabas de una cultura sectaria no
precisamente a esto va a apuntar mi
próxima pregunta porque tras la
captación a jóvenes empezaban un proceso
en el que se les pedía que abandonaran a
sus familias no algo típico de las
sectas entonces es precisamente esto lo
que te quiero preguntar no las hierbas
son una secta
si las hierbas del plan de dios son una
organización de características
sectarias de la iglesia católica esto
ocurre en distintas organizaciones que
son pertenecientes a la iglesia católica
y podemos identificarlos por distintas
cosas la ideología que hay detrás esta
especie de círculo cerrado donde
solamente unos pocos son los que pueden
entrar por lo tanto hay un proceso y un
sistema concreto de captación de
personas que deben ser parte de este
círculo dentro de este proceso de
captación ocurren distintas cosas como
alejarte de tu familia alejarte de tus
amigos y empezar a pedirte que en el
fondo toda tu vida se enfoque en lo que
hace la institución estas instituciones
también suelen tener líderes
carismáticos que muchas veces incluso se
le atribuyen poderes mágicos en el caso
de las siervas del plan de dios había
una monja de nacionalidad argentina que
después se fue a vivir a perú por muchos
años
y ella tenía la capacidad o el poder de
mirar a las chicas a los ojos y
descubrir si dios las llamaba o no a la
vida religiosa entonces se empieza a dar
toda una una práctica en donde se
idolatra
y donde todo se hace en torno a las
peticiones de este líder y por lo tanto
se van traspasando los límites dentro de
la relación que se genera al interior de
la comunidad pero se corta el vínculo
sobre todo con todo el mundo externo
todo lo que no sea de la institución
finalmente viene a ser parte de algo que
promueve un enemigo que tienen en común
y que por lo tanto hay que luchar contra
ese enemigo entonces esta condición
genera que tú solamente te sientas
seguro dentro de esta institución y que
te cortes lazo con todo lo que hay
afuera por lo tanto tampoco puedes ver
aquellas cosas que son negativas o
aquellas cosas que van atrás tocando tu
psicología tu sistema de vida en el
fondo ahora bueno en el libro recopila
muchísimos testimonios cinco años no de
una investigación sumamente exhaustiva y
un testimonio muy particular camila que
da cuenta que da una imagen muy cabal de
las consecuencias en la vida de las
víctimas de las sobrevivientes no por
llamarlo de una manera de otra forma más
explícita
te había contado que había ingresado con
tan solo 18 años y se había ido casi a
la mitad de sus 30 años cercano 40 y te
decía que no podía como seguía viviendo
como una monja no no podía hacer cosas
básicas trámites de la vida cotidiana a
los cuales estamos acostumbrados de
hecho la voy a visitar emocionalmente me
queda instalada en los 18 te dijo ya te
encontraste con muchas sobrevivientes
que quedaron marcadas para siempre ya
si todas las mujeres que han pasado por
las hierbas del plan de dios tienen
distintos tipos de marcas en su vida
algunas ocasionadas por el abuso físico
psicológico o el abuso sexual y es algo
que jamás se puede recuperar al 100% por
lo tanto es una marca que queda por
siempre
pero también me topé con otras personas
y con familias también que han sido
literalmente quebradas por esta
institución y esas huellas tampoco se
sanan fácilmente tenemos jóvenes que
entran y conocen a las monjas a eso de
los 14 15 años incluso algunas mucho
antes
entran a la institución a los 18 y salen
algunas incluso 20 30 o no sé otras 10
años después de haber estado al interior
y todo su sistema de vida se rige por lo
que les enseñaron las siervas del plan
de dios por lo tanto todo el proceso de
reinserción social de reinserción
familiar después de haber cortado lazos
vínculo es muy difícil que ellas no
puedan retomar
y muchas también se encuentran en
situación de desprotección económica a
raíz de los abusos que han sufrido y
necesitan hoy día tratamientos
psiquiátricos tratamientos psicológicos
y no tienen los medios económicos para
financiarlos o por no haber estudiado
por ejemplo una carrera universitaria
dentro de las hierbas del plan de dios
porque había una selección en donde solo
algunas podían estudiar algunas carreras
las otras hoy día no tienen ninguna
ningún medio para sustentar su vida y
vuelven a la casa con padres y adultos
por lo tanto están estas mujeres están
totalmente desprotegidas además de haber
sido abusado hoy día están en la total
desprotección camila nos quedan apenas
unos 30-40 segundos para finalizar la
entrevista pero no quiero dejar de
realizar de la siguiente pregunta el
grupo de siervas se ha reducido
muchísimo en la actualidad no obstante
sigue existiendo tienes información
sobre cuál es su situación hoy en día si
las siervas del plan de dios siguen
existiendo siguen teniendo comunidades
en distintos países entre ellos chile
perú ecuador colombia italia eeuu están
en muchas partes del mundo
efectivamente se ha reducido la cantidad
de monjas que está el interior de la
comunidad pero yo tengo información de
que hasta hace muy poco todavía han
ocurrido a abusos y todavía sigue
existiendo el mismo sistema que
conocíamos entonces es muy preocupante
porque hoy día puede ser que muchas
jóvenes incluso estén en una condición
de secuestro al interior de la comunidad
la iglesia de perú el arzobispado de
lima está haciendo una investigación
pero hasta el día de hoy no se han
tomado medidas concretas ni a favor de
las víctimas y en contra de la
institución abusadora que mira
justamente muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france mit
y 4 en español muchas gracias gracias a
ti nuevamente a nuestra audiencia el
invitamos como siempre a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france mit y cuatro.com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]